[Aplausos]
gottardo finalmente um sonho realizado
eu ficar ou sair para tentar sentir um
pouco e este ano
neste momento a visão por favor do time
eu creio que não está no primeiro site
deve estar no último consegue aperceber
ok meu nome é felipe sarmento eu venho
de leça da palmeira e trago vos um tema
que minha cara
vou falar um pouco sobre mudar o mundo
como começar e o que cada um de nós pode
fazer efetivamente mas antes de começar
eu gostava do roxo dizer que qualquer
palavra que eu possa proferir não tem
como intenção de dizer este efetivamente
o que me é é apenas um game para
podermos fazer a mudança
são mais respostas fechadas com
perguntas abertas porque eu vou dizer
disse estarmos num no instituto de
física no ensino superior
provavelmente deverá existir aqui o que
chamou de ensino em fazer e eu não o
conheço mas há dias vi numa tela de
toque
o comediante brasileiro chamado morreu o
fazer uma pergunta qual eu gostaria de
vos contar também
qual o blog já terminou os estudos e se
encontra no mercado de trabalho
bota ter qual voz treme no estudo de 50
no mercado trabalho 30% mais coisa menos
coisa ok qual nós efetivamente aprendeu
aqui o que estudou ou melhor os 16 17 e
18 anos que estiveram a estudar o que
você efetivamente aprendendo conseguir
falar mais alto e lixo
esta pergunta ou estas perguntas foram
algumas das perguntas que eu há uns anos
atrás comecei por fazer perguntas como
por que é que uma aula tem 50 minutos
alguém consegue dar uma resposta porque
existem turmas porque existe tops da
campanha porque todos temos de prender
os mesmos conteúdos ao mesmo rito onde
todos nossos diferentes tendo gostos e
desejos e vontades de frente o que se
aprende dentro do edifício escola que
não se pode é o primeiro fora dela o que
acontece na bahia e pará que a escola
nos preparar alguém consegue levar uma
resposta científica e pedagógica algumas
destas questões
eu fiz essas contas ao longo dos meus
últimos sete anos
efectivamente aquilo que me aconteceu
foi a ficar em estado de choque porque
efetivamente mil mas aquelas perguntas
têm uma resposta lógica e científica não
tem não existe até o que eu percebi
se efetivamente que não acha atualmente
estamos a visar com crianças século 21 e
tentarem ser ensinadas orientadas por
professores do século 20
sou modelo e psicológico do século 19 em
que esse modelo psicológico seccional é
fundamentado na pet do convênio do
século 17 em que eu dizia se possível
ensinar tudo a todos como se fôssemos um
só percebi que hoje existem que o
segundo doenças fantasmas como a cepêra
terminadas como os déficits de atenção
às dificuldades de aprendizagem são tudo
invenções festinha se a gente ficar
assim como a ritalina já que o chama de
pior a atenção fi e efetivamente o
seguinte ao longo de toda esta minha
passagem da educação de que as duas
primeiras grandes conquistas do homem ou
do ser humano é é a primeira era
aprender a andar
a segunda é a primeira falar
efetivamente nós quando entramos na
escola o que é que nos fazem crer calma
e 60 ou seja nem como efetivamente essa
aí de duas primeiras grandes conquistas
de nós seres humanos
eu estava na áfrica uma uma frase de
joão ferreira em 1920 que está escrito
qualquer coisa dizendo a escola é
invenção do diabo efetivamente possa
saber dizer coisas algo forte possa
dizer coisas que provavelmente nenhum de
vós alguma vez já ouviu mas é abordada é
que naquela altura eo perseguiu seguinte
percebi que toda minha passagem pela
escola tenha sido uma falar se sentindo
enganado
preocupa-nos a ninguém efetivamente no
corpo bisava porque na altura também
tinha o mesmo jean paul sato é que eu
dizia que nós não vemos ser responsáveis
por equipes
nós efetivamente o que vamos fazer como
aquilo que fizeram nós efetivamente ao
ler jean pulsado filshie clip paulo
freire terá dito no início do século 19
que é isso que o céu não transforma o
mundo a educação muda as pessoas e as
pessoas transforma o mundo há 13 anos
não conhecia tinha há 13 anos
foi precisamente o ano em que eu
conhecia que o fair que melhoria na área
possibilidade de não poder transformar
até 11 anos foi pai pela primeira vez
até 11 anos percebi que teria uma missão
de vida bem mais ampla do que aquela que
hoje sonhava outro sugeria ter eu e
atualmente sou o pai de três filhos e
muitas vezes costumam dizer que nenhum
pai você deve queixar do filho que tem
porque efetivamente os nossos filhos são
o nosso flex porque efetivamente aquilo
que nós criticamos no outro é sempre
algum tipo de característica que nós não
gostamos em nós próprios a mudança traz
uma célula ela não se deu no enviado
foram precisos apenas seis anos para eu
conseguir perceber que a transformação
em mim próprio deveria e teria de
acontecer
então eu nessa altura o grande dizer que
fui para a educação com medo do aparelho
hoje posso dizer que estou nem educação
com determinação de vencer nessa altura
fazia aquilo que hoje se chama de
arquitetura do edifício fumar em
arquitetura
ao final desses seis anos eu percebi que
efetivamente é que o que estava
operacional é para fazer arquitetura
pessoas e não a arquitetura do edifício
o que aconteceu efetivamente foi eu
envolver num projecto educativo um
projecto educativo que hoje podemos
chamar escola mas não é uma escola é um
projeto educativo que fica em leça da
palmeira e que chama projecto igreja
quer dizer criança em dialeto africano
até o que nós devemos perceber o que uma
escola efetivamente na minha definição
da escola escola são soja
as pessoas são os seus favores e
princípios e quando transformamos esses
valores e princípios
em cartas o que vai variar são projetos
coletivos e esses projetos coletivos é
que o que hoje nós chamamos de
comunidades de aprendizagem é que o que
hoje chamamos de escola
ao estarmos a fazer isso também estamos
em sorocaba
não podemos esquecer do cm é diferente
de criar porque criar um ser inato ao
ser humano criar supõe efetivamente
defender a sua cria educar vai para além
disso
educar é ter é capacidade de nos
transformarmos de nos reinventarmos
todos os dias a cada segundo porque
efetivamente o mundo conforme já foi
dito
rola uma sociedade extremamente local
não sei se você já pra não é que para
educar
não existe ninguém que nos solicita uma
carta de habilitação especial como para
conduzirmos no estado nós efetivamente
temos que ter uma carta de condução mas
para educar uma criança não nos pedem
nós mas qualquer tipo de intervenção até
o que é no site nós percebemos que a
escola pode e deve ser um parceiro da
família e que como nós fomos escola não
podemos apenas formar que a escola eo
edifício a escola também é um edifício
mas não é só o edifício
o projeto do que eu falo efetivamente é
um projecto numa fase instituinte o que
isso quer dizer
é um projeto que efetivamente todos os
dias tudo os minutos se transforma
porque tem essa necessidade de
acompanhar as barreiras os conflitos que
vão passando no nosso dia a dia
cria o fórum caminho do propósito desse
projeto
o propósito deste projecto foi criado o
conjunto de pessoas que fazem parte
desse projeto
então o propósito dar qualquer coisa com
uma equação matemática é feita neste ego
que nós aqui tenta então nós gostamos de
dizer que o projeto elege é uma
comunidade de aprendizagem é cento e
vivia se humana eu gosto muito dessa
palavra é centro de vivência humana
porque é precisamente na vivência humana
que se gera as barreiras que se geram os
conflitos que se gera alegria que se
gera fui cidade e não são projetos
utópicos não são projetos de hedwiges
não são projectos em que tudo
efetivamente acontece de melhor forma
é tudo diferente é efetivamente uma
comunidade de aprendizagem é que é todos
acordam e que todos acolhe efetivamente
todos aqueles que nos procuram acolhemos
e cada qual de uma forma individual é
que temos e damos as condições para
aquelas crianças jovens e adultos
poderia ser sábios e frisas inspirando
para uma mudança
esta palavra inspirar para a mudança
é efetivamente também muito importante
também como já foi dito hoje nós não
sabemos o que vai ser daqui a 60 anos
se não sabemos o que vai ser a mim é
quanto mais do que 60 anos
para nós é importante o seguinte é
importante perceber que todas estas
crianças e jovens devem ter aquilo que
nós chamamos de uma boa mala de
ferramentas para que consigam se
reinventar
segundo é apaixonado criamos falar
também que o projecto herege é de facto
deve ser visto desta forma como novo
dono de uma rede de aprendizagem
o questiono de uma rede de aprendizagem
e um nódulo que partir dela
nós conseguimos desenvolver projetos o
cae e que parte desse projeto nós
criamos desenvolvimento humano e
sustentável para a comunidade
criamos também falar da estrutura neste
projeto a estrutura deste projecto não
está assente numa estrutura vertical uma
estrutura em pirâmide em que nós vamos
subindo escalando é até o topo não
existe meu chefe não existe um patrão
o que existe efetivamente é uma
estrutura altamente horizontal em que
todos são responsáveis em que todos são
efetivamente autônomos
ok estamos a synthes ou vários dias como
sócio crescia a democracia os efe -
mesmo porque nós costumamos dizer só
podemos passar a autonomia ao outro se
nós próprios foram os autônomos
por que nenhum professor nenhum educador
nenhum orientador nenhuma pessoa usar a
equipe não tem um professor não
transmita que o sabe
um professor transmitir kill team no
fórum pedindo um espaço de aprendizagem
neste projeto
o espaço de aprendizagem são qualquer
espaço é o codó é o jardim são as tendas
de fé biblioteca qualquer espaço certo
como os passos de aprendizagem não só no
espaço mas também devemos falar sua
metodologia e é utilizado em todo este
projecto não existe fundamentalismo não
existe uma metodologia única existe um
conjunto de metodologias neste projecto
não aquilo que todos nós no ensino
convencional estamos habituados a ver
com as turmas os ciclos os anos os tops
da campanha os horários iguais para
todos
não existem aulas expositivas em que
temos o professor é professar álcool
para o outro
neste projecto existe o uso por exemplo
da tecnologia como também já foi
cafalado efetivamente porque tecnologia
acreditamos nós serve não para
substituir o homem mas para humanizar a
escola é para ter visto um conjunto de
metodologias é que o que nos vai fazer e
fumar é boa mala de ferramentas que quer
uma destas crianças e jovens poderão
levar para o seu futuro
cria também falámos um pouco sua
autossustentabilidade este projeto
isso é um conjunto de projetos que
desenvolve dentro daquilo que lhe
podemos chamar escola
atualmente nós temos é que o que falamos
só batendo mil educadores ajudar
professores educadores é dos pais mães é
também terem a sua formação por ter
grande desafio é grande diferença grande
dificuldade para a mudança
somos efetivamente cada um de nós do
nosso porque porque nós temos uma
cultura pessoal profissional social e
educacional espiritual se quiseres de
cada um dentro do carro nome e quando
efetivamente nós queremos mudar é
pergunta é simples nós gostávamos ou
criámos todos os obstáculos é uma coisa
é querer é outra porque efetivamente
deles
só depende do tipo essa mudança depende
de cada um de nós poderia fazer
diferente e não dos outros é tão a
partir do projeto terenos é que o que
nós acreditamos é que este conjunto do
presente como use academia indicadores
como a rádio o herege como a agenda
cultural como as parcerias que temos com
o poder público local como o turismo
educacional como o projeto ligado de uma
alimentação mais consciente mais
saudável nós conseguimos efetivamente
criar desenvolvimento humano e
sustentável dentro da comunidade estão
um espaço de aprendizagem e dentro deste
espaço de aprendizagem podemos ver
adultos podemos ver crianças podemos ver
os jovens uma num circo do conversa onde
se falava sobre refugiados porque também
temos uma projeto de responsabilidade
social
e foi precisamente nesta conversa como
vamos
uma das nossas orientadoras durante três
semanas até à grécia para protestar num
campo de refugiados a care salientar
aqui duas coisas a primeira é que é
efetivamente necessário uma tribo
inteira pra educar uma criança gostava
de salientar um outro pensador paulo
freire novamente quando eu disse que nós
aprendemos uns com os outros em qualquer
tempo em qualquer lugar de qualquer modo
desde que mediatizadas pelo mundo e se
efetivamente aprendemos desde o dia 1º
tínhamos até o dia em que corremos
porque acelerar o processo de
aprendizagem em 12 13 14 15 16 e 17 anos
o que efetivamente nós não tínhamos não
prontos e vamos construindo porque estas
15 ao filme habituar é de repassar todo
o conhecimento e toda a aprendizagem
neste curto espaço de tempo porque
efetivamente porque já existem estudos
nessa área e nessa e nessa matéria em
que a partir do quarto mês de gestação
todos nós estamos a aprender através do
que o que temos hoje os neurônios países
que deixamos de aprender efetivamente
quando morremos
estou muito simples pensar se
efetivamente devemos continuar a fazer o
que temos vindo a fazer e quando falo a
fazer o que temos vindo a fazer em
qualquer área porque a questão é muito
simples questionar não sei se vocês já
pararam mas é criança profissional é uma
piscina agora nada
esta é a primeira vez que eu tenho um
discurso deste gênero porque
efetivamente é minha forma de abordar as
conversas é precisamente através da
pergunta eu começo bom paulo ou sem ser
um palco é que o que eu faço
efetivamente a perguntar às pessoas o
que é que querem saber porque eu nunca
saí o que as pessoas querem saber e
partir da pergunta
nós bloqueamos um conjunto de
conhecimentos e quando efetivamente nós
entramos para a escola toda aquela
curiosidade vai se mantendo ao longo dos
anos recorda o início
mudar o mundo como pensar que o que cada
um de nós quando fazer é que não está a
pergunta com os filhos no início mas
volta a fazer qual do blog
já terminou os estudos e se encontra no
mercado de trabalho
muito vai a pergunta a resposta a essas
perguntas são várias mas eu vou deixar
da minha linha específica e testa
reinventarmos sonharam e agir e mesmo
para terminar eu gostaria de vos deixar
um pequeno poema sebastião da gama
quando eu escreve o quanto meu deus pelo
sonho é que vamos comovidos e mudo de
chegamos não chegamos a joão frutos
eu sonho que vai me dizer basta foi no
tempo da esperança naquilo que talvez
não teremos basta a alma entendermos
como a mesma alegria aquilo que
desconhecemos e aquilo que é do dia a
dia
chegamos não chegamos
vamos som
obrigado e um banheiro
[Música]
[Aplausos]